foreign
Kathy is going to start us off today
Kathy's over in Austin Texas hi Kathy
how are you
great thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
so I've heard you all advise against
using credit cards in favor of debit
cards or cash so my question is why
shouldn't my husband and I take
advantage of getting credit card points
for travel expenses that are required
for work but are going to be reimbursed
by the employer
so your employer is so poor they require
you to advance them for your own travel
no sir
well why do they require you to advance
them for their own for your own travel
you're traveling on behalf of an
employer and they're not paying for it
in advance why are they making you pay
for it for them
well that's that's the established
protocol
yeah
why
I don't know we haven't asked them yeah
you understand that if they decide not
to pay you one month that those are your
credit cards
this is true and you understand that I'm
the guy that's been counseling and
coaching people for 35 years so I'm the
guy that had the guy walk in with eleven
thousand dollars on his Amex That was
supposed to be reimbursed but when he
went to the office that day there was a
padlock on the door and they'd filed
chapter 11 he got NADA he had eleven
thousand dollars on his Amex Amex didn't
care if his company had gone broke they
wanted their money
understandable
um it's kind of a problem isn't it
for him absolutely
for you why are you different
well we haven't we have an experience
that same situation that you just
destroyed I know but you're exposed to
that exact same risk
this is true and all for an airline mile
it's almost impossible to use
so I I think if you're gonna you know if
you're willing to take that risk I'd be
very scared about it a lot it is
standard in Corporate America somehow
Corporate America has conned its
employee base into taking a loan on
their behalf
with the promise of repayment
um and taking the risk for that and
acting like it's not no big deal but it
is it's a real deal I've noticed it many
many times going sideways on people the
other thing people do is they run up
stuff on their credit card ah because
they're just not watching this not
reimbursable and so they end up with a
reimbursement check that's less than a
balance that's right yeah you could you
could spin in something on that credit
card and think oh I'll get reimbursed
for this but Becky down in accounting
might not think so
and so you're on the hook for that but
you got an airline mile but you got your
airline mile
and when you use a debit card the
strangest thing happens you pay more
attention because it's like real money
so here's the deal Kathy couple things
number one when you use a credit card
you are likely to spend it to spend more
than when you use a debit card period
tons of research showing that because it
it doesn't have the same friction that
marketers call it in your brain a lot
more so your chances of spending more
are higher where you're doing it on
behalf of an employer hoping for
reimbursement your chances of making a
mistake are higher uh obviously you
don't think that any of this applies to
you but it does
it does and so you're just more
susceptible to risk and to problems uh
and then the third thing is this
and I think the most compelling argument
is this
I have never met a single millionaire
this is Dave you know
I made it all on my airline miles
[Laughter]
that was my breakthrough my financial
difference the Difference Maker in my
financial plan was I took a billion
dollar company that studies consumer
behavior in depth and I was smarter than
them I whipped them I didn't spend more
and I got airline miles and I actually
used the airline miles I actually gamed
the system and I became a millionaire
because of it never met one not in 30
years of doing this well let me take it
a step further I know a lot of middle
class broke people who think they're
gaming the system and are welcome
strutting around acting like they got
something with an airline mile but they
really didn't at the end of the day I'll
take it a step further Dave
I don't like supporting companies
Tire uh model for having revenue is
built on failure failure to pay failure
to pay on time I don't like that I like
companies that offer a service that
really would like to help you and they
get revenue from giving you something or
helping you do something or giving you a
service I
could port a company where the only way
they make money is by people failing to
pay failing to pay on time that's that's
the the top seller right there I don't
like the way they get them in the churn
is they offer an airline Mile and oh by
the way Consumer Reports says 78 percent
of the airline miles are never redeemed
so I know Kathy's may be in the 22
percent but and she may get 100
reimbursement she may never overspend
but you are playing with snakes Kathy
look everybody says I pay my car
this there's a trillion
dollars
in credit card debt so somebody's lying
yeah and it's up right now yeah and
somebody's you know and I got to tell
you the number of people that we've
coached out of credit card debt over the
years that said it you know it all
started because I was trying to get a
free airline ticket mm-hmm
and and here's the other one this one's
humorous to me this is not Kathy didn't
bring this up but we'll just keep on
this subject for a minute
um the Discover points you get you get
two you get two points back yeah so you
get two percent two percent
so here's the deal you spend a hundred
dollars
to get two dollars
explain to me how that causes wealth
that you in order to get two dollars you
spend a hundred yeah what math class did
you people go to
the school of the broke yeah I'm telling
you it's that that's the kind of stuff
that's out there and so what I studied
and the way we came up with the process
that we use here is
common sense that Grandma had and I
studied where companies are being
predatory and I stay away from snakes
and I studied wealthy people
and I find out what wealthy people do
yep and yes some wealthy people Kathy do
have a credit card and some of them do
pay it off every month
but none of them claim that that was
somehow a financial breakthrough that's
right and and you're already spending
more mental calories on this than it's
worth even if you're getting full
redistribution on this so
you ask why that's why you spend more
you're more likely on a travel expense
account to spend money that's not
reimbursable because oh I get Marilyn
miles back oh I buy I'll buy two instead
of three I'll buy three instead of two
because I get my Airline on this back
um and uh so you're more likely to spend
more you're higher risk when you are
loaning this Corporate America
characters your money
hoping they're going to pay you back
each month
scary stuff
and we have seen the times that they
didn't you can't just assume assuming
they'll get you in trouble you know what
they say about it yeah I've heard